what a wild week I'm back to work for
now three whole days after having been
off for a month it has been wild and had
a buddy of mine I was running to him
last night he said he said but some of
the stuff you've been through and and
some stuff I'm singing about you this
week do you ever do stuff on the air
that you regret and I went good lord
dude I've been on the air for 30 years
three hours a day five days a week
that's tens of thousands of hours of
opportunity to screw up
of course I've done things I regret of
course I've been on stages in front of
well over a million people in live
audiences in the thirty years that I
speak I've spoken have I said some
things on stage that were cringe-worthy
oh you bet sometimes intentionally
sometimes I go back and go I don't even
know where that came from
well what was I too much coffee for I
walked out there I mean yeah so yeah I
mean this is a fun world I live in
because everything I do just about is
live and then worse than that it's
recorded and played over and over and
over and over and over and over and over
and over and over and over and over and
over and over and over and over again so
yeah that's part of my life
and so I get the opportunity you know
the ones are reeling I told him I said
that you know the only thing I really
regret now I made some mistakes but hey
you're gonna make mistakes if you're in
the ring swinging right so I'm okay with
that
I've done some stuff that's
cringe-worthy probably wouldn't do it
again but I was in the ring swing and
I'm okay with that you just you know put
your dukes up go at it you're gonna hit
some stuff sometimes you know it's okay
the only thing I don't we thing I've
quit doing these the only ones I regret
are when I've done rants where I
attacked a person and somewhere around
20 years ago I made a decision that I
don't do that anymore
on the air I will attack an idea
big time big time and that there's
people that I just from a distance that
I really don't like but that's not the
point the point is for me to talk to you
guys and to teach and I talk
about an idea you know and so you know
but I I there's there's YouTube out
there of me floating around it from the
old Fox Business days when I had a show
on there attacking
individual and individual about
something and I wished I hadn't done
that
and I teach our Ramsey personalities I
said don't do that you know and so
there's lots of people out there that
teach things that are opposite of me
that say negative things about me even
and I just I don't want that that's
that's one of the thing I don't do but I
man I tell you what we had we did a
video one time with a bunch of
coordinators in it from Financial Peace
University and put pictures of those
people in a brochure and it came out
about two years later while we were
still using the video that one of those
guys was arrested for child pornography
so you don't we did we threw those
brochures away and we edited that video
and that guy's gone
right because certainly don't wanna be
associated with that we certainly didn't
know anything about it at the time but
you talk about cringe-worthy jeez and I
you know you know the you remember the
old guy the Crocodile Hunter
wasn't he lovable that killed remember
him and his kids are running around
their precious now doing shows and stuff
and it was the show we all watched and I
used to do a joke and it was anyone the
old FPU videos and it was a funny joke
um but but it was tragic and I used to
say you know if you keep playing with
credit cards you're gonna get bet you
know that God missiles those crocodiles
when these days he keeps missing those
dangerous animals he's gonna get it well
he did get it right and it was
completely uncool to leave that video
out there right it was a funny joke
while he's alive but you know it was
pretty bad taste and cringe-worthy to
leave it out so we edited that video and
took that joke out and obviously we
don't use that joke game where it's not
funny cuz the guy got killed bless his
heart right and it's not so I did a rant
on Monday about the overdramatic
traumatization of the earthquakes in
Puerto Rico and the fires in which are
all bad things the fires in Australia
and I even made fun of on Monday get
this I made fun of schools local schools
last year a perfectly sunny day and
there was a prediction of a line of
storms coming through that might have
tornadoes in it and they closed school
and I was making fun of them all
whistles 12 hours later Nashville gets
hammered right talk about cringe-worthy
that's cringe-worthy and so I mean 3
o'clock in the morning I'm up because I
got people calling me their stuff broken
everywhere there's you know stuff we own
and she's what a mess and people that we
know are hurting and all this kind of
stuff well I mean obviously I still
think it's stupid that you cancel school
the day before on the prediction that
there might be a tornado but talk about
bad timing to say something like that
right before my own community all the
people I love gets slammed because
nobody hadn't by the way no one
predicted the tornadoes Monday night in
Nashville there were no predictions of
them as a thunderstorm there were not
tornado activity predicted 24 hours in
advance and we got hammered this
community is hurting right now and so it
would be bad taste wouldn't it not to
leave that rant with that line up of
course it'd be so immediately we took
that rant off the air off the podcast
and we edited out of the YouTube account
Wow now that we put the rest of ran up
without the tornado comment because it's
bad taste I mean it's bad taste to talk
about the crocodile guy after he died
you know on video even though at the
time your point was still valid but that
doesn't matter but you know snowflakes
rather Dave Ramsey has to be held
accountable for his tornado joke
and we have to hold him accountable
because because I'm a wuss and and he
edited that stuff out and is hiding from
it no I edited it out because it's in
bad taste you goofus you know and it's
really the worst possible timing to make
that very valid point because they to
actually have nothing to do with each
other except that there's a tornado
involved at exactly the wrong time
twelve hours later we get hammered what
are the chances of this and be like me
doing the crocodile joke and the guy
gets killed twelve to twelve minutes
later you know I mean just be awful what
horrible timing so yeah out of an out of
good taste and because my
friends and my community are hurting we
pull that stuff down so in case you
wanted to know is pull down there's a
piece of the podcast that's missing from
Monday because of my mouth
so if you want to hold me accountable
for something snowflake here's what you
do listen to somebody else because I
don't really care if you're in my
audience you're too stupid that's how
you hold me accountable so yeah I'm
going to be in here swinging and I'm
gonna be in here making jokes and I'm
gonna be in here cutting up and I'm
gonna call out whistles when I see
wusses and the I'm gonna break stuff and
I'm gonna keep doing this I've been
doing it for thirty years and that's why
18 million people listen to the show
every day and it's not gonna stop and if
you want to [ __ ] and moan about that
you can but you're blocked on Twitter
already if I could block you off
listening I would because you're too
stupid to help so move on and go listen
or do something else my gosh you people
need to get a life your wusses seriously
but there's a difference in regretting
this and being held accountable and
apologizing versus having good taste in
the middle of a cringe-worthy moment and
the world's worst freakin timing I hope
you understand the difference this is
the day Ramsey Chef